well i spent what uh spent the better
part of yesterday trying to teach my mom
and my sister how to create coinbase
accounts transfer
answer bit by bitcoin transfer bitcoin
uh sean do you think that angel
investing like is this gonna be what's
the future of sean pury i mean
do you think that this is gonna be your
full-time job angel investing
is a way to for me it's like just
dipping a net
into a stream of flowing water with a
bunch of fish inside i'm not
taking a boat out spending you know an
afternoon out in the water
fishing and trying to catch something is
this in front of my house there's this
stream with fish going through and if i
just put a net in
i can catch some great fish that's what
angel investing is for me and that's
what it's been basically for the last i
don't know
six seven years where my own friends my
own personal network
or things that come inbound through
getting more popular on twitter and
podcast it leads you to some
opportunities people want you in their
deals and you get to see deals early
and before i used to sit on the sideline
i watched a bunch of those companies get
big
and then i started you know i asked a
rich friend hey
if i give you a good deal that you
invest in can i get a piece of the carry
i said yeah
that's how i got into lambda school
which is already kind of like a big
winner
and then as soon as i did that i was
like man instead of a big like instead
of getting a piece of this guy's carry
why can't i just do this myself
so as i got a little more money i
started doing it myself and then with
the rolling fund that just lets me do it
on steroids where i can just do more
and so what percentage of your net worth
well could let's be you cannot answer
this but let's just say that you invest
four million dollars a year in eight
years
how much income do you think you're
gonna do you think you're gonna make an
additional two hundred dollars do you
think you're gonna make 200 grand a year
do you think you're gonna make it so do
the millions so a a good fund
is gonna like let's say 3x it's money
over the kind of like seven to ten year
period
uh great will be you know five x or more
and like if you're
if you count if you caught an uber if
you caught a coin base
uh you know you're laughing your your
returns are gonna be super skewed just
by this one
company that's now worth tens of
billions but let's assume for this
conversation
let's assume you're only using so let's
say you're the first um let's take let's
take three x let's take the most cons
like the most conservative version of
winning right is i triple the money
so over the next three years i'm gonna
deploy 12 million dollars let's say i
three x that money that's 36 million
dollars
um that gets that comes back into the
fund after returning the money
so uh so a total of 148
million dollars and so on the 36 that's
the profit
i get to keep 20 of the carry right so
that's about 7 million
ish is my mental math right um you know
roughly seven roughly seven million
dollars and that's seven million dollars
over a let's call it eight
eight to ten year time span it's not the
biggest like that's
that's why i don't go all in on it is
because i can make way more money
building a business in that same amount
of time so
if i well in seven so but that's there's
a recap that's
your mind how much in you say seven
million that's my fault
yeah that's a significant amount of
money that's a million dollars a year so
you're thinking this will make you a
million dollars a year for seven years
starting in seven years no i think it's
like kind of like a lump sum that you
get in seven years
more like it i get nothing for for seven
years and then as these companies
as the as many of them die and some of
them do okay then a few winners
emerge eventually you reach a steady
state where you keep going and you are
making
a millionaire yeah really what's
interesting is where you scale
and you start doing you know 20 million
or 50 million a year 100 million a year
uh and you know eventually that's why
you could see yourself hiring investment
professionals you could have a whole
fund
has any years paid out ryan yeah yeah
but i i but i think there's another
important point is it's not just about
money it's about well-being
as i'm always saying on the show like
it's about like
what investing has done for me is it's
been a vehicle for learning and for
connecting to really interesting people
and for like getting to like kind of
like go on these fun adventures where
i'm like learning about like the latest
things in crypto or
the latest things in e-commerce and i'm
connecting dots and then
the other thing it's done is it's made
my my primary businesses
far more successful because i'm
borrowing ideas i'm learning like oh wow
look how this e-commerce company does
performance marketing i've never even
heard of performance marketing until
and then i brought it back to a
newsletter company and i'm like oh at
our newsletter company
we can buy facebook ads and google ads
like this ecom
company that i invested in called warby
parker or whatever and like i'm now i'm
like cross you know i'm taking you know
kind of like what your show has done a
really nice job but does it no does it
distract you from your main job
well that's that's where like that's why
i think it was smart that this guy hired
some people and how you know sean's
hiring some people because
then then you can kind of like be as you
said in two places at once
but no that's you just have to you just
have to take the risk of hiring a
hundred and fifty thousand two hundred
thousand dollars well you're not you
don't have to i mean
i i haven't done that and i've still
made a bunch of investors but but i
missed a lot of investments because of
that very reason because i was like
hey i'm really laser focused on biz now
and summit and powder mountain i'm not
going to
look at a deal every day i'm going to
look at like a deal every like three
weeks
and so i'm just gonna miss a lot of
stuff you know i missed like
i mean i i have a one of my the ceo of
my company invested 150 grand in a um
in a in a crypto hedge fund and he's you
know he's up to like
almost six million dollars of value i
don't know if i should be saying that
here but
you know he i missed that because i was
just like i'm busy i can't look at that
right now yeah that's totally true and
by the way most of the time when people
say like
oh it's not about the money it's about
the journey it's about the
learning it's about the people you meet
you know the kumbaya thing
normally that's like you know that's the
tell
it's actually almost always about the
money because if you took the money out
they wouldn't do any of the [__]
this is actually one of the rare things
where that's actually true because i
actually was doing all these things i
was meeting founders i was helping them
with their businesses
i was getting excited and digging into
new spaces i was keeping a fantasy
portfolio of like
to learn like oh i'm tracking these
spaces
and i think these are going to be big
and i want to learn about these spaces
and here's some of the companies that
are doing cool things and let me
observe their growth tactics from the
outside and try to see what's working
and maybe apply that to my business i
was literally doing all those things for
fun
before i ever put a dollar in uh you
know i was subscribed to like
i don't know 50 different um angelus
syndicates because you didn't have to
put money in but you could get the
investment memo because i literally
loved the learning so much and i
had no plan at the time to be investing
in any of those i put zero dollars in
sorry to all those syndicate leads you
know i was that annoying guy that was
subscribed and never invested
but it was because i actually genuinely
actually wanted to learn and i wanted to
meet these
founders and so this is one of the rare
occasions where when you hear that
normally it's [__] in this case i'm
100 on board which is everyone and like
that's how i that's exactly how i think
about it is this is like a
my other friend described it as like it
it's a great way to just blow off some
entrepreneurial steam
it's like you your brain if you're
operating a business you all of a sudden
start hearing about vertical farming and
crypto and then like you know oh what
the hell is you know
what the hell are nfts and like you
learn about all this [__] and then
part of you is like should i be doing
that like what the [__] am i doing this
stupid like
real estate newsletter i should be going
out there building you know this
ride-sharing company or whatever
and so investing gives you a way to like
get the high and dabble in that and have
some financial upside
but you don't it lets you stay focused
as an entrepreneur so that's the other
like
like weird psychological things that
comes from investing is
aside from the learning aside from the
good friends you make and the network
you build and the learn you know
the cross ideas you get you literally
just get to like it's like a release
and uh and then you can go back to doing
your thing do you
but but are you sean are you the reason
i i did the syndicate thing
i'm doing it with joe and we're i i bet
my own money it's
it's kind of like a rolling fine but
it's not uh it's only deal by deal basis
whereas sean you have like money
that you could deploy a little more
freely i didn't do the rolling fun thing
because i didn't want to have customers
that i have to uh
appease and talk to on a regular basis
because i didn't want like a job
do you feel know now that you have like
a job because you have a hundred people
who have given you yeah
no i write a once a month update uh and
i like doing it anyways it's just hey
here's the new companies we invested in
why i would do that for my own
documentation anyways what was the
conviction at the time i made the
investment here's what i believe here's
why i believe investing in it
i like having that anyways for five
years from now that's an important thing
for me
so in this case i just publish it to my
investors great
um so that's the that's all the
maintenance that goes into it there was
a little bit again early on of like
actually getting the investors on board
but i took no meetings i took no phone
calls i just said here's the link
and because of this podcast because of
my newsletter because of my
own track record and the deck i made
that was enough to raise the money for
me and i know that that's kind of like a
not everybody can do that part most
people would have to go knock on a bunch
of doors and really sell this thing
um so that's that but the other thing
you mentioned like for you if you just
get busy and you just don't care about
angel investing
you could just not do a deal for the
next six months and no sweat whereas for
me i actually do need to deploy this
money
and so there is like a certain amount of
like startup pitches i need to take
every month
in order to be doing great investments
um
and so you know i actually have to
deploy this money i can't like
just sit on my hands and decide i want
to go go on vacation or like just
go super heads down in my own business i
can't like i can't do that because i've
taken on a fiduciary like obligation
to deploy these people's cash right what
what i thought would be man
i used to invest i don't know like 50k a
quarter 100k a quarter max
and now i have to deploy a million
dollars a quarter
and actually i run out within the first
two months of every quarter so so it's
actually not been an issue
because i just my check sizes are bigger
and once people know you're investing
they send you deals your friends send
you deals
they're like hey i'm doing this this is
a good deal and they're like oh wow i
didn't need to
like the fundamentals make sense and all
is all the good there's other good
co-investors there i didn't need to go
find this deal it came to me
and that's that's the best best thing
that happens what percentage of
what percentage of your liquid net worth
did you allocate to before this
because now with the rolling fund i'm
investing rpm right other people's money
i only put
a small amount of my own money for the
fund before this
i was doing roughly 200k 250k a year
was what i put in and i don't remember
what that was at that time of like
liquid net worth it was like kind of
substantial like it was it wasn't
wasn't i don't know half a percent or
something it was like
like that mattered to me but also if i
lost that money or
like i knew going in at the very least
this money is locked up for a long time
i can't use it to go
buy a vacation over or under 15 over
under 15 or 10 percent like was it more
than like 10 because that's a lot
i don't know i'd have to think what what
i don't know how much money i made at
the time because i made more money in
the last couple years than i did
back then so i don't know actually how
much money i had then what i do remember
is thinking
when i very first started i thought i
need about 300
000 of a bankroll to even do this to
have enough of a portfolio to give
myself a shot
because angel investing so many of your
deals are going to be losers
and so i thought okay i need to have you
know 20 to 30 bets i need at least 300
to 500
000 of bankroll to go do this and at
that at the very beginning i didn't have
that that would have been an
irresponsible amount of money for me
that was like at the time
i don't know half of the money i had or
something like that so i said okay i
can't do that
that's why i started talking to other
people and being like hey if i scout for
you can i get kerry
and you put up the capital and that's
how i got started
[Music]
i really like this as opposed to buying
public equities
when you have very little money because
of the learning and the connections and
like the benefit that that could have on
your own business
like i was betting a very high
percentage of my money initially
and it really helped me because i rather
than just buying like coca-cola
or walmart or some publicly traded
company where i learn
nothing i meet no one you know i it
doesn't really help like the day-to-day
of my like newsletter business or my
community business or you know the the
real estate business if these things
were basically benefiting
my ability to make money on my day job
so that's why i
i actually think when you're small it's
actually not a terrible idea and in fact
a high point i've read a tim ferriss
thing a while back
he wrote a long time ago before before
he started investing and he was
basically like i'm just going to fund my
own mba
like if i was going to spend 200k yeah
business school i think i can learn more
investing that 200k in a mix of you know
public stocks and
private you know startups and when i
read that i was like oh absolutely like
i will build a network i will build
business knowledge i'll have skin in the
game and actually
this might become a profitable thing you
know but the worst case scenario this
was my
rather than going to you know wichita
state and like going get my mba like why
would i not do this so once i read that
that's how i started thinking about it
was like i'm going to put 120k in
that's like that's business school and
let me let me just get going
well so we we not only thought about
that with investing but we
we lost 25 000 on the first summit we
held various
private summits in between summits where
we would lose 20 grand here 10 grand
there to throw like an event
and i always saw that as an investment
like you're saying like in like my
network or my learning
and the same thing i was talking to a
guy the other day about he wanted some
coaching
and he was like debating whether i was
worth like the monthly amount and he had
like 400 grand
in his savings and i was like well what
do you want to do what else do you want
to do with the 400 grand
he wanted to put it into like robin hood
and buy stock and i was thinking like
man if i had known about
coaching or consulting or some of the
things i now know about
you know like trainings that you could
go get online
you're taking like a writing course from
like you know purell online
like those things are so valuable like
they're so worth the like three grand
here the five grand there that
if you have you know a little bit of
money saved
i think that's so much better than
trying to make like you know the index
return on the stock market
when at least when you don't have that
much money i i think um
somebody said to me you know concentrate
to get rich diversify to stay rich like
when you don't have much money like put
your money into building yourself up
building up your learning building up
your network
and then later when you're when you're
much richer then diversify and
have a you know an allocation and a
portfolio like that
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on
the road let's travel never looking back